foreign
Amy's with us in Dallas Amy welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Rachel and Mr Ramsey I'm not sure you
remember me but I called earlier this
year kind of overwhelmed with prosperity
um Rachel we bonded over the craps table
bit but um
oh you're one of those okay they
ended up like me at the end of the go
but I took all of your guys advice
except to increase my lifestyle so I
kind of have we've kind of been having
this like under budget problem and what
we've been doing is just putting all
that money into the market
which I like because it's down right now
but then psychologically I feel like I'm
trying to time it which I also shouldn't
do so I'm kind of like what do I do with
the extra money
now I'm still under budget and I can't
help it
having extra mileage there was a great
problem maybe okay so remind me I'm
trying to remember could you please run
for Congress uh
so you're out of debt both my husband
and myself are Engineers
um I'm 33 he's 32 baby step seven yeah
back then it was 1.7 or 8 million now
it's probably like 1.6 million net worth
but you know who cares way to go you've
killed it well done so what do you do
with the extra money that you have every
month is what you're asking and you feel
we are putting it into the market
because you feel like you're trying to
time the market and you feel like you're
motiv you're right and I know I
shouldn't but like I guess I would do
that even if it was up too because yeah
with our extra money is we just but
you've not increased your lifestyle
because I remember talking to you and
saying you guys need to enjoy some of
your money and you haven't yeah that's
our problem right we've been so much
how much extra um I'm thinking like it's
been like five five thousand a quarter
oh not much
no no I'm not talking to some people but
in your world you're worth two million
dollars you're 32 years old it's it's a
thousand fifteen hundred bucks a month
okay
yeah yeah and so I don't know I just
it's like do it I don't know if you're
gonna tell me just find something to buy
or do whatever you want no no I mean I
wouldn't go buy something just to buy it
but I do want you guys because you're
both Engineers that know how you're
wired so like I do want you to enjoy
life and so increasing your lifestyle
some I would take some of that if you
haven't yet and yeah increase your
lifestyle by a few percentage points and
throw some of that extra there and then
Amy you know I'm just thinking like what
Winston and I do we have a money market
account that extra money will go into
after we've done everything if we have
any extra it's okay it goes in here and
then we kind of have a short-term goal
so whatever it is whether it's replacing
a car or we have a big five-year goal of
doing a pool one day at our house we
really want to pull so we're kind of
putting money towards that but we like
we're working towards something
um and so that's always helpful for us
to have that thing that we're working
towards so if you and your husband you
guys have anything that you want to
accomplish or do in the next five years
um I don't know but I guess maybe that's
part of the difficult thing I don't know
what the next school should be yeah I
mean it's like okay what I did upgrade
our house yeah what I did at your stage
was I just threw the money I just threw
the money and I was in a mutual fund
until it was enough there to buy some
real estate that I paid cash for it was
a simple goal and so
um and I actually
um I bought a little lake house for
almost no money after I got my first a
couple hundred thousand in there and um
that that little lake house is now gone
and now we have a bigger lake house but
it started a whole trend of us buying
real estate with leftover money I'll
give you something else to do that I
think you really do I think it'll be
good for you after talking to you for a
minute
budget 300 a month for outrageous tips
and random generosity at the gas pump
and I want you to walk up with cash and
look somebody in the eye and blow their
mind do that for three or four months
and then tell me you hate it because you
won't be able to say that it'll blow
your mind three or four hundred bucks
out of your out of your thousand or
fifteen hundred just just just you don't
do it for the rest of your life but
you'll probably end up doing it the
restaurant